hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to road of the dead now this
is another one of my favorite flash
games from the past but this one was
literally way way ahead of its time and
you'll see what I mean when I'm playing
this right now it is astonishing what is
done in flash so many years ago when
this was made but this is just all based
on the flash engine in the horrible
programming that's associated with it
but it's just really really cool if you
play this game and chances are if you
love flash games you have it's an
awesome game with awesome music and like
incredible gameplay use it was almost
what I would call and I don't use this
very often but revolutionary because
it's totally different than any other it
is crucial that you stay in your home
and out of sight uh-huh
martial law is now in a thing ok anyone
trying to exit the city will be shot on
sight yep this is not an exercise you
know I know stay home okay now you see
some shits going down in the city there
happens to be a Zombo attack
they're everywhere I'm just a lonely car
mechanically
I think I said this is bad I can barely
hear my inner thoughts
you just got up and started walking
I'm not staying here
gotta make it through the highway okay
it's probably my best bet to get out of
the city yep okay so this is where the
actual game gets going basically you're
just driving through the city trying to
escape and this is where the cool part
comes in I played this before I know how
this all goes let's do this let's go
so you what's cool about it is that I'm
not sure if it's entirely randomized but
it definitely procedurally generates the
game as you go through it and basically
you're just trying to drive through it
as you go that school bus is full of
blood I don't remember the head from
when the first time I played this so
many years ago and I spent a long time
playing this game because there's just a
lot of stuff that you can do morons
don't run towards my car and you gotta
try to get rid of the zombo's and you
get a lot of points based on the farther
you go before your entire car blows up
and there's some interpretive logic of
how you know you blow up your car and
then you get back and are able to repair
an upgrade to your car and then go again
that's besides the point but the main
point is that this game is freaking
awesome and I loved every second of it
do not run towards my car oh yeah II is
honking horn and II your horn can either
attract the zombies or make pedestrians
kind of move out of the way
which is the main problem about zombies
driving cars and that's ridiculous no
how about you don't excuse me pardon me
sorry sorry didn't mean to do that I'm
all the way in Monroeville now
relatively decent thing
you're about to not be very sorry about
those guys later on the game because
they could give no thanks yeah the thing
about the zombies is that they're not
exactly the easiest to kill and they
kind of go in huge numbers and the more
they kill the bigger their horde becomes
blowed up real big so now that I have RP
I can upgrade my car and the first thing
you wanna upgrade is your engine you
want to go as a faster exactly you want
to go fast all right also handbrake I
forgot about that water jug oh yeah
that's right water jugs can put out your
car just in case you're on fire as
you're blasting down the highway you
want to make sure that your car is
properly you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maintain your position they're dead and
slow for Christ's sakes just kill them
all they're hard to kill sir they're on
the way little baby boy I don't like
zombies are gonna eat me oh by the way a
long time ago I played a game called
segue of the Dead which was kind of a
the maker of the stand his name is sick
that fiend is liquid his handle whatever
and it was really funny because that
game is actually a parody of this one
but you're hiding on a Segway I'll put a
link to that video in the description
it's really funny but uh this aim is
like super super cool just because like
what I didn't catch what you said but
I'm about to go through a checkpoint
here so don't like me I want to be light
up smoking bad for you no negative on
that one
damnit you ran right into me are you
kidding me maintain your position the
next checkpoint will handle ya the next
show carries on highway 65 we were to
intercept and shoot down the target over
Oh God
well that went well I'm glad that
happened oh well cars people and chaos
that's what I must expect
I just can't crash my car out there I'm
dead I'm sorry I didn't know that I was
gonna be a problem subjects will be
chaotic I need to get through oh why
would you do that that's so horrible
don't do that stop okay
wipers I forgot about the wood no I
didn't forget about the way percent knew
about the wipers okay so now I got armor
on my car so I can hit more stuff as I
go by and hopefully make it farther into
the game so it gives me a little target
reticle too if you hit him at a certain
spot you will like splatter them which
makes it easier just to plow through
zombies okay so we're doing much better
here and actually the horn will bring
them in right on target to the point
where you want to lay
I'm all over your windshields and you
gotta wipe it off don't you hate it when
you get splattered all over and you
gotta wipe it off
no no one knows where I'm talking about
oh well your blood not your blood these
poor civilians just running in the
middle of the streets with the zombies
we're not gonna have a good day Wow
wipers
Opie was a zombie come on now be a
little peaceful about this we don't need
to immediately jump to the hey kill a
little extreme to be honest sorry did
not mean to hit you was honestly not
aiming for you buddy
nobody gets out of the quarantined area
highway 65 personnel sorry I'm sorry
sorry
god I'm sorry I didn't mean to just get
blown off me those are actually upgrade
is I'm intercepting new tries why can't
we be friends why can't we be friends
why can't we of [ __ ] why can't we be
friends so you got a dodge out of the
way oh [ __ ] I think I just creamed the
civilian all over the floor just mad
splattered never mind I blasted someone
all over the road not gonna happen
cuz I know your tricks what they do is
they pull the spike trips in front of
your car like they're sneaky but they're
not sneaky enough to stop me about know
about a bunch of no so you got to be
mindful of them wherever the
oh geez oh geez I gosh gosh [ __ ] okay
well that didn't go well for me
hopefully I can get through the next
checkpoint without being bothered you
know bothered by death bothered by a
bunch of explosions oh my god that for
civilian oh geez oh geez
I barely see through help this zombie
blood Oh God
they got me oh they got me oh they got
me oh my god oh jeez oh that hurts
bullets kind of hurt oh jeez okay we're
gonna be we just gotta get through this
next cards I believe in the heart of the
car yes okay we made it through the next
circle we can blow up and safety
[Music]
yeah that'll work
also Hellfire means that there's going
to be a helicopter coming after me real
soon I'm shocked that he's still moving
forward because frankly God when one of
those when one of those upgraded zombies
get on my car it's going to be very hard
to shake them off and then I'm gonna be
dead in the water I'm a maracanã dead in
the water given that my car's smoking up
a storm air my tires are gone you don't
need to worry about that anymore
you can barely control my car as it is
I'm fine and that's fine okay so
continuing a highway there's gonna be
tons of abandoned cars an accident okay
so the windshield stands someone's
having fun
okay so better tires what's the wheel
should make it easier perception I can't
afford that horn a little port is
actually a surprisingly good have done
out of the way okay so that's enough for
now I'll save it for the rest yeah I
have a horn but the horns actually
better because it will help line
things and they get the civilians out of
way coming to know me I think I see you
I'm pretty sure I see all of you
why are they so focused on me when
there's a whole bunch of zombies that
are all kind of you know doing the thing
with the murder
[Music]
it's it's sad cos it's that you can hear
the civilians like hey come on please
let me in and then I know oh hey I'm not
stopping for these chumps no no these
chunks get out of my way chumps but to
lose your chumps
[Music]
Yesi that's the catch-22 of the
situation see I'm trying to escape but
I'm also knocking down like all of the
defenses than the house set up I'm kind
of being a dick here almost in the next
checkpoint almost there don't kill me
see like it's all for the greater good
that they keep but I'm just like and I'm
gonna do that because I like winning the
going to send everything they got at me
even helicopters gonna be yourself it's
gonna be Jenna for now or to get through
all the carnage yeah I'm gonna need
Turnage oh yeah I forgot punching that's
right but I'm not gonna punch out I
don't need that if you really pissed the
military off they'll send telegrams yeah
no joke I already know this okay there's
a way to get rid of this guy and it's by
letting her getting him to hit himself
on the traffic signs so if I can just
line up the shot Oh
dammit now's a waste get over here oh
[ __ ] this cupboard
okay so I can get rid of him
and just one more spooky move here get
over get over get over get over get over
go it sure is good that they're wasting
all this military hardware trying to
stop me charges
Hey
you're out about that oh my god oh my
god good thing they explode in just a
particular pattern this ain't good
this ain't good who's the opposite of
good I don't even know if I had a
checkpoint good thing they need keep
needing to reap repeat those orders my
face and body full of bullets there's
got to be no bomb a captive sorry
[Music]
[ __ ]
I'm almost there another okay but I put
out my fire right before I blew so
that's good okay so we made some good
progress
I'd better be prepared another bowl of
this feast they better get out of my way
Spike's trick deployed target
approaching
never seen their farewell but keep your
heads cool and we're gonna get food
follow my orders
defensive line ammonia [ __ ] River our
backs to the water will make a final
stand
we also have reports that some zombies
of the general is in town I still need
to worry about these evolved Dom bees
but it's quick evolution on the zombies
it's almost left 4 dead quick but that's
ok you don't need to worry about hey
buddy get him on the next
cuz if this guy stays on my ass I'm just
gonna be dead anyway
so I gotta make sure that he's taken
care of good [ __ ] Wow well that was
short-lived next one over here come on
buddy miss miss miss miss miss miss I
gotta go backwards
Hey someone was unhappy about something
oh god I forgot but I should come off
okay you can shake the hall [ __ ] that's
not good oh don't get me don't get me
there we go you don't even want to touch
those ones those ones have you if you
even come close to them they're gonna be
all over your face if you need a gun for
them I took him with me oh geez
you cannot you can't tell me what to do
you're not my real dad [ __ ] just went
right over the spikes good for me sorry
evolved ones are gonna be nearby
well here we go nope not today buddy
[ __ ]
today not today not today not today okay
I hid a lot of things will you hit by
him those [ __ ] are definitely
getting getting gritty with me
I do not feel good my body armor has
done nothing I got a gun for you I got a
gun
I can make it to the next second I just
gotta make it to the next checkpoint and
I'm good I can make it I can make it
took way too many balls from that guy
so casual
I thought the bombs were gone bombs are
back baby hello nope he's having such a
good time and there's gonna be a pocket
[Music]
they're not exactly letting me through
here they're kind of still shooting at
me the shooting bullets kind of hurt as
opposed to the throne bullets don't line
them up you said let me through general
he promised
Oh
General Sherman rains
Destin's they're going to have choppers
I'll need to dodge them or destroy them
it's not I need to focus I need to focus
handle here we go now I got this upgrade
called perception which allows me to see
more parts of the road and see like
different things coming out like there's
a soldier coming up well that was good
yeah so this general actually knows what
he's doing and he's setting up a plan
and as with most zombie apocalypse
scenarios there's one final plan usually
for a scenario like this that you guys
know about boring sorry
not really
I'll get him on the next Maddie bro
oh the crowd of school buses
just like it's so it's so weird that the
school buses are just like blasted all
over the road like completely ripped
open with blood everywhere
you wanna play too bad oh geez I just
saw a plane go by that means there's
gonna be carpet bombing soon I don't
know from where I don't know from one
bullet left so I can only get hit by
another one of these guys once you know
boy the best I can
oh [ __ ] then the boy
[Applause]
[Applause]
I don't think I need a Hellfire how far
is it
I just gotta make it to the next
checkpoint
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
anyone dance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if I let them
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] that was nuts that should
not have been that hard that was
infuriating you guys only saw a montage
of failure but for some reason lead it
down I almost made it there without any
upgrades and then all of a sudden like I
tried that for 30 minutes it would not
repeat like for some reason I kept
getting shoved in doing explosions I
kept getting blasted all over the road I
kept getting tossed around like a rag
doll and my windshield like the more I
upgraded it the more fragile it became
it was so weird it was so bizarre and
like for some reason every time a
helicopter spawned I was not able to get
in the rhythm so hopefully no one cares
you're stupid and ugly dumb no one likes
you
[Music]
sorry I honked cheese did you see that
lady just get blown up
yeah that's a miss man hit that one yes
because for some reason it wasn't
reliving it quite like that just there
and they're really coming in man
whoa
goodness gracious we are in the thick of
it now
oh no no I got blowed I got blowed why
did I get blowed I didn't want to get
blowed thank you thank you for repeating
the orders that you've been ordered to
do for a long time now
our spikes already do that
[Music]
Rodi Rodi wrote it at the top general
sorry we're going to try and stop
creaseman do it and then get your ass to
the I gotcha River hey stop it for these
chumps are total failure
oh Jesus bad progress that's how it's
supposed to be amigo debase I'm
currently at sixty four point seven and
thirty two point four heading to seventy
nine you guys can guess with the the
silent eagle whatever it was called is
doing remember what I was talking about
how you know there's a final solution in
more most of these zombie scenarios
that's
quick this is their support approaching
drop zone permission to engage over
hopefully I don't get another helicopter
sorry sorry
oh geez oh geez this is probably gonna
do me in well I gotta do me in here
how about no how about no oh it's gonna
blow I'm gonna [ __ ] blowed last stretch
there's gonna be a [ __ ] going to send
everything they got at me necessary
sacrifice with the greater good
well that was unnecessary
god damn it all with his thick
I was tossed all over the road there
this is just with the zombies and a few
survivors okay it's gonna take some epic
driving in this we can't do this we can
we are gonna do this if this virus or
whatever it is spreads we could lose the
whole country the entire world they will
be a fair
take point time debase we missed our
transport and are heading to the iake
river on foot we'll be there in about
ten minutes
Penta meal the base target in sight
well this is sad oh I got plenty of
bullets more bullets than I needed sorry
lady well you were gonna get blown up
anyway so what's it really matter I'm
still happy about it apparently oh come
on I better not miss this one
[Music]
maybe time I don't know how far away it
is but I think I'm gonna make it
[Applause]
so
there it is okay we're good we're good
yes it's an eagle today's the drop is
airborne detonation good very nice
actually I don't even know if it's
scripted at the end there if you're
actually racing somewhere you're just
going to get there eventually because
that was kind of in sync with the timer
but I'm not under the chair sir ten
seconds
[ __ ]
oh that's right it was a combination of
evil dog and sick death fiend so anyway
so that is row to the dead that took me
a lot longer than I thought it would I
recorded for about an hour 20 minutes
but it was fun fun fun fun game and
there's a lot of different game modes
that you can play there's a lot of
different difficulties and now is this
RZ good but then there's like survival
mode and all that cool stuff so there's
a lot of cool stuff out here thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know if you want me to play the sequel
that's out there is a sequel and it's
super fun I actually have never beaten
it myself
not because I'm not good enough but
that's very likely but because I haven't
had enough you know for some reason I
just never played it's not that I wasn't
interested in it I just never played it
to the end so thank you everybody
someone for watching let me know what
you thought in this game in the comments
below and if you want me to see you me
you play the sequel and as always I will
see you in the next video the red light
somehow doesn't make me feel any better
[Music]